je vous le disais la préfecture de
police de paris a annoncé hier soir le
retour du port du masque à l'extérieur
dans la capitale dès vendredi pour le
réveillon du nouvel an et jusqu'au 2
janvier les bars vont fermer dès 2
heures du matin les rassemblements
donnant lieu à la consommation de
boissons alcoolisées sont aussi
interdits pour bertrand legrand médecin
généraliste pour éviter l' isolement et
pour éviter de devoir vivre avec le
virus il y a une seule solution la
vaccination écoutez si si je me raisonne
qu'en tant que médecin j'isole tout le
monde dans sa chambre et au bout d'un
certain temps l'épidémie va disparaître
oui mais c'est pas possible on peut pas
isoler le monde entier et quand vous
êtes à 200000 contamination par jour ça
fait 2 millions d'arrêt sur dix jours
glissants vous rajoutez les cinq cas
contacts ça fait quelque chose comme 6
millions de personnes à l'arrêt 7
millions de personnes à l'arrêt c'est
pas possible en fait on va pas devoir
apprendre à vivre avec le virus on va
devoir affronter le virus s'est pas
exactement pareil on n'apprend pas à
vivre un vrai qu'un virus on se protège
contre un virus et on se protège
essentiellement se vaccinant ce qu'ils
n'ont pas compris et ont malheureusement
raté le coche mais dans toutes les
batailles il ya des premières personnes
qui se lèvent qui sortent de la tranchée
et qui sont fauchés par la mitrailleuse
c'est comme ça